good morning ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage Gary Vaynerchuk
[Applause]
thank you thank you good morning good
morning good morning welcome to voice
con I'm extremely excited about this
when I think about what the team has
done to get us here I'm just very proud
and so obviously when vaynermedia and
Vayner X in general decided to start
putting on events in 2018 we thought a
lot about the IP or the places we wanted
to play and so before I go into this I
just want to give a huge shout out to
Kim and Emma and the rest of the Vayner
experience team and everybody at Vayner
I'd love for you to clap it up for them
[Applause]
you know one of the things that's
interesting about you know having an
event be your event versus what I
normally do which is fly in and speak
and give a keynote is you you know being
a host is definitely different than
being a guest or a special guest and so
I give a lot of thought to the rest of
the lineup as this was being built out I
was just overwhelmed and impressed with
who we were able to get lined up for
this event and so to try to reverse
engineer why you're here and think about
the value that I can bring in the lineup
I think that respecting your audience is
always the most important part to create
success as a matter of fact probably as
a quick side note the most interesting
thing for me and the voice space is that
we have not established kind of the UI
in the UX and the interface of how we're
going to interact with these things as
they become dramatically more
sophisticated that comes along with
empathy and respect for the end user you
being at this conference all day the
empathy and respect I have for you is
that we have a very detailed curriculum
and line up at this event where I think
a lot of people are gonna nerd it out
and so I'm not gonna nerd it out I'm
gonna go in a little bit of a different
direction I want to set up the framework
of why this event even exists and why
for many of you who if you follow me in
any shape or form are hearing me
pontificate and and push and prop
propaganda this space it comes down to
it was interesting Matt Guerin who's
gonna do a great job after me hear from
Boehner asked me literally or Kim just
asked me Matt just asked me actually he
said what he gonna talk about I looked
at him like I have no [ __ ] idea and
and it was really interesting because
the reality is I don't but i but i but I
do and and I do because of the following
in my you know career at this point in
my life it's been interesting to watch
pattern recognition as I was sitting
back there getting ready for this talk
the only feeling and kind of thought and
vibe but that I had was very similar to
the vibe I had the first time I was
sitting in front of seven liquor store
owners my dad's liquor store was part of
a co-op where
were other owners and they all kind of
own shoppers discount liquors they were
independent but they were buying an
advertising co-op and I remember going
to a meeting in 1996 where I was gonna
let them know that I was starting a
website and we're in this meeting and
I'm like yeah we're gonna launch this
thing and we're gonna call it why my
brain calm which was already a little
weird because we were shoppers discount
liquors and I just remember the enormous
scrutiny and almost disrespect through
everybody spaces because basically what
the energy of that room told me is that
nobody's gonna buy wine from this
internet thing I believe that more than
half that room had no idea what the
internet was right and so when I sit
here today this is a pretty fancy you
know event meaning not only are the
speakers pretty educated and far along
with technology and business but so is
the audience itself and I've been
thinking a lot I'm like huh it's really
quite interesting that nobody in this
room including myself actually fully
understands how deep this is gonna go
and here's what I mean by that I think
it's very hard for us in this room at
this moment at this apex of text
messaging and mobile addiction I think
it's hard for us to understand that
there's a high likelihood that in 10
years that so many of you are gonna give
up on texting for voice AI devices it's
just hard to make the leap that what
you've now become completely
foundationally living on as your
execution of communication as a platform
is going to be disrupted no different
you know it's funny I love when young
becomes old I love that there's so many
people in here that I know and so many
of my friends that are now in their 30s
40s 50s who were such thought leaders 20
years ago 25 years ago about digital and
social and the Internet itself who now
are gonna struggle with this transition
who don't think they're gonna stop
texting in the same way that they made
fun of people who didn't think they were
gonna text
a decade ago and so I think for
everybody here I think there's a lot of
entrepreneurs here and a lot of Fortune
500's here and I think the theme for me
is you're about to hear a lot of
incredible data right when you you know
depending on the study you look at when
you look at 50 to 100 million devices in
home already
you know AI Voice devices in the
marketplace when you think about how
many more that's going to be in the next
12 to 24 months but more importantly for
the people that are advanced in their
technology thinking when you know and a
half decade it's not even going to be
those devices and it's gonna be
integrated into every single product in
our lives including when your showerhead
is voice-activated and you remember
something that you need to do and you
just tell somebody you're gonna be 10
minutes late or what's my meeting
tonight at 7 I don't think that we have
quantified our unbelievable addiction
for speed everything that happens
pretty much I'm a simple guy I talk a
lot about day trading attention a lot of
it is just predicating the fact that you
guys hate friction that we as a society
give up everything privacy we will give
up privacy all day to win back three
minutes
we just love speed we subconsciously
understand that time you know you hear
that saying time is right we
subconsciously deeply understand that to
me it was really fascinating early on to
see you uber succeed watching Travis
navigate that business and later as an
early investor what struck me so early
on is like these people can't afford it
I was looking at some of the data like
they can't afford it why are they taking
these $28 right they can't afford it and
what you just start realizing is
convenience is king I grew up in retail
convenience as king is super duper real
there is nothing more convenient than
voice infrastructure around us period
this space is going to win and it's
going to win in a big game and in a big
way this space is also unbelievably
fascinating because it is not visual let
me explain to you why this matters I'm
gonna paint you a scenario when you
think about the search engine more
of the early 2000s even when Google won
and became a real dominant force and
they started having an ad product and
people started freaking out how powerful
search engines were when somebody would
type in coca-cola and Pepsi had the
ability to have an ad even to this day
in the small screen of a mobile device
even when somebody buys your category or
your brand as an ad you're still showing
up organically in the UI of the visual
and if I'm typing in Reebok even though
there may be a Nike ad if my intent was
Reebok and even though I might be
seduced for a second by that Nike ad my
intent going in was still that and I
have the ability to buy that what's
fascinating to me is we do not have that
luxury invoice what's fascinating to me
about voices the players that win this
game Amazon Google Apple Facebook I
assume has to be doing something
secretly in some [ __ ] secret
warehouse
and anybody else that we can't see
whether it's a china-based Tencent or
somebody else or something else that is
just too - 18 year old gal's right now
in tennessee who have an idea and are
able to put it together and get there
whoever it's going to be they're gonna
have remarkable and I mean remarkable
leverage to me the Internet is the
foundation of our society and then
you've got four to seven internet
companies that are the layers on top of
that and then for every one of us here
our job is to be the next layer above
that these toll booths Google Amazon
Apple invoice are set to make so much
more money and have so much more power
it's also why for the people how many
people here run or think they have a
brand raise your hands so this is super
important to me in the internet age we
have had incredibly fascinating
confusion between selling and branding I
listen to people every day talk about
business and they don't realize that
they're just salespeople but they're
talking like they're marketing or
branding what they care about is CAC and
LTV and last touch attribution and
really just hacking math based marking
which I'm a huge fan of I just think
it's half of the equation I think the
art and the creative is the other half
and I've spent the last decade being
fascinated by you know Wall Street and
Madison Avenue just being completely
based on subjective art and [ __ ]
reporting and then Silicon Valley being
disproportionately addicted to math and
not realizing that that eventually runs
out and that becomes their vulnerability
to me the thing that I'm probably most
passionate about with voice is the fact
that brand has never become more
important every single person here is
going to buy an obnoxious amount of
products goods and services on a voice
device in a decade and I mean most of it
when that happens
you will start realizing why things like
Kleenex and Xerox and uber were the most
important place if you do not start the
process right now of branding Chips Ahoy
over cookies what's going to happen is
we're just going to say
alexxa or Google sent me some chocolate
chip cookies and our battle is going to
be Alexa send me some chips of Hawaii
because I promise you because Amazon is
a [ __ ] gangster if you say Chips Ahoy
you've got to get those but if you say
cookies you're getting Amazon's private
label and/or Mondelez in that scenario
is paying a good drill Ian dollars you
know I laugh when I meet with my CPG
clients they come you know they're
they're concerned about the amount of
money they have to pour into trade and
for the entrepreneurs in this room that
means good end caps at the Walmart when
you walk in and how much they extract or
whether they're on Deal they have to
subsidize the coupon price that's gonna
be child's play compared to being the
default product when somebody asks for a
category product when you ask for jeans
how much is Calvin Klein or Levi's gonna
have to pay to be that product versus
the margin that Amazon makes in having
their own private label versus Google
going out and buying Levi's and owning
it and making that the default my
friends I think the Amazon purchase of
Whole Foods was a watershed moment that
finally got people to understand that
this is just starting that these
companies have a lot of leverage when
target cells to Amazon or Facebook or
Google people gonna start waking up to
what's happening and the thing that's
fascinating to me is that voice in a lot
of ways has that parallel impact I do
not know I don't know people think
people understand how much voice is
gonna affect the entire restaurant
industry there is no open table or resi
or things that were Yelp
there's voice and the smarts is
something I think a lot of people going
to struggle with how many people here
saw the Google presentation with the
assistant making the resident just raise
it high what do you think that
technology looks like in seven years
right I mean this ship is getting
continuously smarter the other thing
that fascinates me is the things we
think we don't want versus the things we
do want I think that most people when
the propaganda goes against voice
devices
listening to you people gonna talk about
that scary that's [ __ ] I'm not gonna
have one privacy yet I think 9 out of 10
of you are not actually gonna care about
that and I think that so I think that
watching the counter-arguments of what's
going on is super fascinating cuz I
think we grossly underestimate how we
actually work and how psychology is
actually wired I think we are in the
early stages and so for me being laughed
at for website in 96 or being completely
looked upon you know as I sit here today
the other feeling I have is the feeling
I had in November 2005 when I decided
that I was gonna start a YouTube show
after the holidays for my wine show and
and that YouTube literally did not have
a video yet that there was not a single
video on YouTube that had a million
views it was a baby and I watched my
entire hundred-person staff at Wine
Library in February of 2006 think that I
lost my complete mind that I went from
working hard and doing my thing and
buying and meeting and you know tasting
and doing this and now all of a sudden I
was locked up in my office filming this
thing trying to get people to watch the
show on YouTube and so that and then
obviously investing very deeply and
probably the biggest parallel for me
about this conference and for and the
biggest feeling I had backstage which is
the conference that completely changed
my life was boa in 2007 there was a
conference in February 2007 in London it
was called phowa Ryan Carson put it on
it was called the future of web apps and
I remember it was I went to it and I
remember just sitting there and
listening to the presentations and I
remember thinking that my life was gonna
be different from here on out that I
fully understood that this internet
thing that helped grow my family
business
and sell stuff was just starting you
know obviously when you're impacted and
I would say the biggest fear I have here
how many people here feel that they've
been positively professionally impacted
by the internet or social media raise
your hands it's my biggest yeah it's
such a you know it's my biggest fear
because that's what happened to me in
2007 I'm walking in and I'd
right I built this business I made it
and I remember luckily in that
conference I realized my team makes [ __ ]
like this is just starting this is this
is not even the net forget about the
national anthem in this game I even even
left the home yet to get to the parking
lot to tailgate this is just starting
and it really switched for me and made a
totally different commitment to this
device and more importantly to Twitter
and Facebook which obviously changed the
career path of my career my big hope
today through the details of the panels
and the keynotes and through the QA that
I want to serve up here in about 10
minutes
where we can go details and I'd love to
answer any of your questions of what I
see or what we're seeing or how it's
going is that this becomes the watershed
moment the reason I wanted to do voice
con is
not since social media 2005 6 and not
since internet 94 95 had I felt the
chemicals in my body that have dictated
my career which is I know what you're
gonna do before you know you're gonna do
it and I know that everybody here is
under estimating how voice is about to
change their lives and how that affects
you as a human and how that affects you
personally and how that affects you
professionally is something that I want
you to really ponder please please don't
be like a lot of my homies that came to
those social media conferences with me
in 2006 and 7 and didn't fully see it
and now talk to me 10 years later and
regret not squeezing harder or betting
harder or being in it harder because
they knew it they saw it but they were
too passive and/or they underestimated
how big it was going to be to me in the
same way that social has clearly changed
not only business but politics and
psychology of our end user and just who
we are as human beings voice is gonna
have that same ability you know it's
crazy how many people here have children
under 8 the education they have around
their interests because of you know I
mean it's crazy like like the knowledge
of 5 year old has around information
that they're interested in when they
can't read
right yet is fascinating I mean for
everybody who just raised their hand
your kids know so much about something
that they could have never known because
they would have had to read it and now
they've got it in their head at scale
on-demand always when they need it and
what that's gonna do for us is
remarkable you're gonna be in meeting by
the way this is the death of bets you
know like the random bet like you get
into an argument your buddy and like
you're trying to figure out who's right
how many touchdowns they scored or how
many square footages or what did it
you're just gonna get the answer and
once it's not you know it's because
you're you'll never believe how lazy we
are that's what I thought the mobile
device was gonna do but you still don't
want to grab it and google it you'd
rather literally [ __ ] debate it for
another hour cuz it is fun and we'll
always keep those human elements but man
I'm gonna tell you something the passive
nature the ambience of voice the
complete zero friction this is still
friction as crazy as it sounds grabbing
it and doing something is still friction
this is not and so for me this
conference is unbelievably selfish I'm
being very frank this is an unbelievably
selfish conference because I'm very
excited that our company gets to put a
flag in the ground in this space I
believe that so many of you are on the
verge of disproportionally impacting
your business because of this space and
I think that there's a lot of things we
need to think about how many people here
own or a very senior executive of a
business great I bet you that you've
never thought about what your business
sounds like like sitting here and
realizing oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna have to have a conversation
with my dad Sasha
about what's the voice of Wine Library
sound like is a pretty exciting kind of
conversation just out of humour for me
as a human but I think it's very
important especially you know it's just
something we don't think about it's
something
that we could have never thought about
in the same way that we could have never
thought about how important a logo was
for social or things of that nature or
your tagline or things of that nature
you know how unbelievably important over
the next decade or two what your brand
sounds like is actually going to be a
variable of success is it a male voice
is it a female voice is it a mix what's
the slang the sound of your brand
something none of us could have ever saw
coming so the other thing I want to
touch on is there's a lot of people in
here who have advantage that voice is
about to collapse for example I think
the biggest stakes being played out
right now with voice are for google
google makes a lot of money on search a
lot I think that search is on call right
now because of the voice space obviously
we'll continue to do visit visual
obviously you'll be in a plane and other
places but I think the amount of search
because a lot of the percentage of
search is searched to action and the
fact that voice can do that passively
guys I'll just I'm bouncing here a
little bit but just voice to action you
know the thing that I'm most excited
about for voice is the fact that my
calendar is gonna be hooked up to it and
so are all the other busy people that I
know and instead of going through and
wasting 28 minutes or five hours of my
admin in my own time to try to schedule
an important meeting over and over if I
just say I want to have a meeting with
XYZ person you know and the fact that
the device is gonna be able to look at
my calendar an app calendar and actually
tell both of us at that moment that
actually even though that you're both
executives in New York the prime time
for you guys to actually meet is in
Houston between 1:00 and 3:00 because
you both have downtime is just
remarkable and just a simple little
execution of what's going to save us
time but technology has always saved us
time and made us more efficient I was
telling my buddy the other day I was
having a conversation was wild how many
how many people here over the age of a
third
five raise your hands perfect so
youngsters you got to hear this back
when we were kids if you wanted to meet
your friend somewhere in public it went
down like this you'd have to tell them
in school that day that you were meeting
at 4:15 and you had a meet by the big
water fountain at the [ __ ] mall but
here's where it gets gnarly if for some
weird reason your mom was running lis
and you got there at 425 there was a
50/50 chance that the person gave up and
you never saw them it's just remarkable
how in a very short period of time that
seems ludicrous because of this and the
biggest framework that I'm looking for
everybody to come away with this is to
dream and imagine and project how big of
a deal voice is going to be for example
when I was in Seattle there's a start-up
working on the number one pain point
like literally Vayner media Vayner X
could go out of business because of the
following thing it takes us 17 minutes
in the beginning of a meeting to get our
[ __ ] PowerPoint up on the [ __ ]
screen I mean there may not be a
shittier product on earth than Apple
AirPlay right it just doesn't work and
we keep thinking it does but it doesn't
they're working on the fact of an app
that you literally walk into your office
and just say Alexa put up the PowerPoint
and it's done yeah we're so pumped so so
time time will always win besides health
time is the thing we value money comes
behind that if you do not understand
that you will underestimate this space
what audio is about to do to our society
is create I'm the reason podcasts have
exploded in the last half decade is
because with technology we can passively
listen to them and do something else
the reason my podcast viewership is
stabilizing but my excuse me my video
blog is stabilizing but my podcast is
growing is so much of my fan base over
time Mike
after a couple of months once they get
the visuals down and they go to the
audio because they can listen to it in
any way any time next year every singer
BMW Lexus all integrating into your car
these devices so funny the great fear of
my life as a parent was like [ __ ]
texting and driving is scary right like
we demonize drinking and driving texting
driving is just like unfortunate has
killed an enormous amount of people the
fact that we're like the age that my
kids are never gonna get to that world
because we're not gonna text and drive
because in the next 7 years five years
10 years we're just gonna talk and drive
like you're just not gonna need it it's
just not gonna happen it's remarkable
how fast you know I talk a lot about
okay now that we have the foundation of
this technology the speed and how these
things turn is gonna be remarkable it
just is and so I really really really
hope the biggest thing you get out of
this conference and you can even tell by
my demeanor it's interesting I'm even
just like auditing myself right now you
know the the hyperbole and the
showmanship and the excitement that I
took tend to bring to stage is muted
this morning because I'm focused I'm
like [ __ ] man like I'm kind of in the
mindset of like [ __ ] do you
understand what's happening here
and like the thing that I love about
technology is so many of you regret
missing out on [ __ ] I jumped on
Instagram late or I wish I was on
Twitter or I screwed up I should have
started a podcast or god dammit I wish I
had an e-commerce site what's amazing
about this game is that if you win the
next thing you make up for all the
losses in the past it's true all the
regrets you may have of the last 20
years of not moving fast enough for not
establishing your agency in that
category or whatever it may be literally
become irrelevant if you can nail this
but please understand one thing
not only has foresight and intuition
driven me but the biggest thing that has
driven me over the last 25 years
absolutely is practicality I am not
ideological about voice I would be
thrilled to post this keynote in seven
years on whatever we're consuming
with the headline of remember when I
totally [ __ ] that up
I have no emotion to this space what
that means is there's a lot of people
here that are gonna want to build their
first skill on Google and Amazon after
the end of the day and I want you to be
very thoughtful about where your
business is right now if you're a
fortune 500 company that makes sense to
me because you can afford it and you
need to bring that DNA into your company
yesterday so that the executives don't
go out and waste money on just random
[ __ ] over the next two years and so the
education then the building is
established but if you're a startup or a
one-woman show in here if that's taking
time and money out of other things
please recognize the size of the
audience is still very early yes there's
a lot of devices in the marketplace but
most people are just listening to music
right so the thing that I please implore
you is I jumped in heavy and social in
2005-2006
but it wasn't driving the retail sales
for Wine Library I wasn't putting out a
tweet and selling a hundred cases on
winelibrary.com
there were other things still doing that
I knew by 2010 1112 that this would have
an impact on my business and so I was
fully committed because I was running
the marathon of a culture change not
trying to get the gold rush of the first
mover I am very fearful very fearful
that people leave this state today and
go home and get really unpractical and
think this is some sort of like gold
rush or drilling oil and it's gonna be
Eureka I do not expect a single person
here to have a skill that they make that
changes everything within this first
year because I just don't see the
consumer behavior mapping to that just
yet but I will say this it just takes
one killer app it just takes one killer
app there's somebody right now fishing
up an idea to build on top of one of
these devices and guys don't get it
twisted these devices and the technology
is this when this came out people
grossly underestimated even when they
were hyped about apps I don't think they
fully understood
that the apps that were built on this
we're gonna be worth the money and
impact the world the way they did ways
Spotify guys whatsapp is an app it's
called whatsapp you know it's sold for
19 billion dollars right it's
foundational to what Facebook does
snapchat these are publicly traded cover
their apps please understand that the
devices are gonna have apps on top of
them that's going to be the game changer
that's the marketplace that Amazon
Google Apple and everybody else is going
to try to build that is the thing that
you're gonna try to build to change the
trajectory of your career or for a lot
of you that is going to be the things
you market on top of to build awareness
or to create conversion for what you're
up to and so if you think about it think
about listening to a podcast right how
many people here are actively listening
to podcasts great as you know a lot of
podcasts are trying to monetize and they
do ads and live reads right there's
gonna be a very different thing when
you're consuming an app or skill on a
device where there's an ad and your
ability to just say buy this then
creates transaction how many people here
have had something show up to their
house from Amazon because they're under
12 year old bought it on Alexa somebody
sent me an email the other day I was
like dude I love you for this voice
conned a good luck at voice con at love
voice but mother [ __ ]
I had a 40-foot blow-up castle show up
to my house
can you tell them to get their [ __ ]
together it's very likely that this is
the technology that's gonna have the
biggest impact on your life so I applaud
you for being here I really do because
what you're doing is what I did in 2007
and when I flew to London you see it you
intuitively understand it I think the
lineup that you're gonna see today is
gonna get deep into the data you can
bring out your pads and take notes what
I want you to do and what I know now
I'll go into the details and thrilled to
go back into the dirt and get out of the
clouds right now and and I'm about to do
Q&A so we're the runners got it okay
awesome so please raise your hand when
when you have questions there's a wrap
up here but please understand this under
estimating this movement comes in two
forms one you're gonna have regret I'm
just gonna wake up in 20 years and be
like [ __ ] I went to voice con and I
still didn't do [ __ ] about it or it's
gonna come in the form of massive
disruption to the things that are
working for you now if your business is
built on top of search or what search is
doing for you you're about to get very
vulnerable over the next decade and so I
highly recommend you take this shift
very serious and start learning and
start tasting and to give you an insight
to what clearly worked in 2005 to 2008
for many people this is about tasting it
this is about if you believe in this you
need to have a device in every room in
your home if you believe in this you
need to hire a developer or rent a
developer or even figure out how to
develop yourself and create a very basic
skill or app calling on top of these
devices download other people's skills
get used to it so you can taste it
you'll be brushing your teeth listening
to your device and realize wait a minute
what that person just did for jumping
rope I can do for my SAS Internet
company you have to taste in these early
days because it's no different than when
you discover a new land right
like when people
new worlds like they get off the [ __ ]
boat back in the day and they see a bush
with some fruit on it that they've never
seen before
and the head person goes you go eat it
and it's either a [ __ ] raspberry and
it's delicious for the rest of time or
the [ __ ] dies but you got to taste it
and so either you're gonna [ __ ] build
a raspberry or you're gonna [ __ ] die
but it's better than not trying it all
so thank you for being here I'll be a
wonderful day and I'm fired up
QA who's got a question great
take it away runners okay right here
first one all right stand on it very
slowly yeah yeah yeah so obviously
you're talking about a lot of the
consumer market right yes because it's
easy to just say buy me this and that
and that what do you see in other
businesses let's say yeah b2b services
what-whatever days yeah well let's talk
about vaynermedia's ambition I we
Sentinel we sent a a dot to all of our
clients last year where we recorded 180
employees voices molded them together
and created vaynermedia's voice and
every day we are ambition is to give
them a marketing tip which is you can
imagine if your CMO or a senior
executive if once we know that they're
not doing it yet we may have one or two
clients doing it but we're getting our
patterns right in three years
if you're a service provider right the
fact that if you can penetrate and I
think b2b is always best because you
know the 200 or 800 but you don't need
consumer success of millions if you
could have your 800 biggest potential
clients or most important clients here
your company every morning for a minute
with a tip about the industry not you
being QVC you being BBC do you
understand you have to bring them value
did you know or like have you seen this
trend not in your self-interest not like
vaynermedia only pushing you know social
media and the person feels it's
propaganda no it's bringing them value
do you understand what's happening at
retail or have you seen this trend or
this stock prices up and this is how
it's affecting your business or this
competitors private equity firm just
sold or giving them value guys it's
always value it's always been about
value the far majority of you like me
because I'm giving you value with
nothing in the expectation of return
it's not super complicated the one who
brings more value has the leverage so I
think beta B's incredibly
I just thought about that but we have an
IT service company so for example in the
morning I knew that there is some stupid
videos update you know [ __ ] servers
up and I tell them like be careful about
this and yeah
always value comes in and it's also
surprise and delight right
I'm just play this out you're giving
them value of information value of
information and then randomly you throw
them a curve ball on a Tuesday April
13th that's like paying today there's
you know we're giving one month extra
free service or freeze this or a free
ticket to voice Connor but you know just
to keep them interested right yeah okay
creative you know one of the things I'm
most excited about in the advertising
world is that there's a lot of
copywriters right now who write copy for
videos but she or he is not unbelievably
passionate about that yet she doesn't
even realize she's two years away for
writing copy for long form skills where
we go down a path and spend six hours
playing Zelda only through voice and
what technology always does is it brings
us back right us knowing everything
about each other and us PR to each other
on social media is just back to the way
we used to do it in a village we knew
everything about everybody you know we
grew up interacting and grew up let me
rephrase we in the 20s 30s and 40s in
this country and all over the world
heavily interacted with voice we soap
opera started as radio shows like I
don't think people realize that gaming
is gonna be done through voice cuz
you're gonna be able to play you don't
imagine it if that's gonna be you know
what happens when you eliminate the
visual of some of you remember playing
like that I did all kinds of imagination
gaming just outside like playing
warriors and just like doing dumb [ __ ]
like you're gonna be able to do that now
so you know there's the reason I'm
bringing up is we have to be creative we
have to establish those cadence hey Gary
is Jim mess come in the Impressionist we
met in LA with my wife you've got a
great mom what's your youtube because I
think really people need to go see this
cuz I think so really good I think since
I throw the right
c'mon or if you look up Jim prescience
if I do celebrity voices - really anyway
someone here now I'm here
but Gary you've got a great mom I've got
a great mom I'd wonder my question the
phrasing says the question I know you
were so busy you were such an
entrepreneur such a busy kid did you
ever watch happy days oh sure okay
well my mom is Marion Ross of happy days
who played mrs. C she has a book she
made a special inscription just for you
and I want you to read it because it'll
make everybody laugh can I bring it to
you you can bring it to me [ __ ] love
happy days super pumped right now it's
amazing to Gary Vee I'm eighty [ __ ]
nine and I'm still crushing it that's
amazing
next that's amazing thank you better yep
sit up
how you doing Gary he had a wine-tasting
event in Jerry's enter yeah well one of
the things I think a lot of businesses
are gonna be worrying is about security
convenience versus security yep so the
question is how do we convince a
business to be more flexible and to
relax on their security policy or maybe
adjust their security policy in order to
look into voice my point of view on this
is the word convinced scares the [ __ ]
out of me I've spent my whole career
talking about stuff that most people
don't believe at the time that I start
talking about it and I have found
through the last twenty five years that
I'm way better off just continuing to
talk about it and not convincing people
but letting the market force them into
my world you would be way better off if
you decide to do something here to go to
everybody and focus on the three people
of 418 that do it with you and do it
amazing for them than to sit there and
try to convince people that are never
gonna go there convincingly unconvince
Abell is just a terrible strategy that i
see so many people spending their time
with i mean i sometimes go into a pitch
and I'm fundamentally checked out within
the first ten minutes I'm like this is
over
like we're here to check a box that they
wanted somebody innovative to be here
they're Al and I'm like and what's crazy
is I'm not like [ __ ] like I'm not mad
at its business I signed up for this I
just am NOT emotional about commencing
people I am thrilled to just stay alive
until it happens and then look at them
and say [ __ ] told you dick you know
yeah thank you
you got it questions I have a company I
manufacture carbon composite parts and
metal parts okay a lot of the parts are
confidential okay how could I put that
in voice or even on just regular social
media
well you can't it's confidential well I
get it but how could I advertise a my
company in I don't know how do you build
awareness to get more business correct
correct who are you trying to get right
now we're doing some stuff with the air
with aerospace companies and basically
more people that are doing carbon
composite parts and that's pretty much
it so what I would tell you is that you
probably need to make videos white
papers and long-form written posts on
LinkedIn that are titled directly for
your industry okay you know what I mean
like six things that people in this
space don't know you need to build up
thought leadership so I mean you know I
blog my day every day Vayner produces
content at scale I produce even more
content but I have clients and we can't
share all that confidential stuff and so
we navigate around it so instead I don't
dwell on what I can't show which I would
listen for a lot of the way I talk about
stuff I would be I mean I'm desperate to
show you how much of this [ __ ] is
actually working for companies but I
can't right so I don't dwell on that I
just focus on creating thought
leadership which creates gateways to
opportunities you need to be putting out
written word audio and video pieces of
content most likely in a LinkedIn
environment in my opinion especially
because post Cambridge analytical you
can't
argued based on you know employees of
which you know a lot of you know i
pontificated about four years and it
worked and now it's gone and so i told
you you know that thing so so i would do
i would do that
thank you but when you make the content
remember i said it don't make it about
you everybody goes on linkedin or lit
like i've watched people take my advice
and they go on and they basically write
a press release you have to make pretend
you're not the retailer or the company
you have to make your tenure the media
company so for example is there a b2b
magazine that Yoram that the targets
that you're trying to reach have in
their industry you need to think like
them because you have to put out
articles that are valuable for that
decision-maker maybe even outside of
your own service right like like we
don't do shopper marketing at Vayner
heavily but i make right up shopper
marketing thought piece lead or ship
thing which is like shopper marketing is
[ __ ] it's just another way to say
trade and that may bring awareness to me
and my company which you then may lead
to them using our e-commerce services
got it if you don't bring value to them
you've lost and when you guys all think
about the skill you should hear the
first thousand skills that have been
pitched to me they're [ __ ] garbage
right i've talked to big companies
they're like gary will make a skill
about the history of our company i'm
like nobody gives a [ __ ] about the
history of your company you care about
the history of your company nobody gives
a [ __ ] that uncle thompson [ __ ]
started the airline in 1912 they care
about like is there traffic to the
airport and like did you stop them from
wasting time or like like you know so
think of always think about them it's
why i push empathy so much once you
deploy it and once it becomes your
strategy you win you become actually
consumer centric everybody talks about
giving a [ __ ] about the customer nobody
shows me in their actions that's truth
you care about your bottom line
financially and it shows so don't make
the same mistake you've made in digital
on voice that will be your breakthrough
questions
a nephew from Toronto just contacts you
in juvie see stuff and I remember so I
guess what do you think the angels and
VCs don't necessary and about the void
space or what's to come um I you know
it's funny if they've been I think if
you have a consumer centric VC who got
to live through app culture she and here
are gonna be very smart
cuz the patterns very obvious you know I
you know so I don't know what they don't
or dunno you know I think that the
biggest issue probably for a lot of
people is that as we try to figure out
the UI and UX of how voice works I think
we're gonna bet on a lot of founders who
have theories but we don't know that
they have the practitioner skillset to
navigate through this world so there'll
be some guessing going on but the truth
is I'm not sure I mean I think to be
very frank and we've talked about this
in person the VC game is kind of
interesting right if your VC it's in
your vested interest right now if you
believe in this space to go invest in 31
companies push them all real hard to
become the Facebook knowing that 30 of
them are gonna die because you're
pushing them too hard and you just need
one of them to get through to pay back
your entire fund that's VC yes good
morning Gary hey I'm dr. Joe Ella how
are you good I'm really excited to be
here Thank You Lea excited to talk to
you excited to be with everybody here
thank you I am an injury prevention
specialist and a sports chiropractor and
I'm going to go from treating patients
to try going online so I wanted to know
how you would imagine a Lexus skill for
injury prevention you know I think look
I mean the question is do you feel that
you can articulate all of you and so I
appreciate the question doctor because I
think it's gonna help a lot of you do
you feel that you can transfer knowledge
that then helps the other person on the
other end through voice my belief is
what you're doing is probably for some
people that have a good sense of they're
like you know I've been working out with
trainers every day for four years and I
still call every one of my
fools the wrong [ __ ] thing I think
just keep laughing at me I just can't
[ __ ] grasp it I have no idea why but
I would say this what gets really
powerful is being able to collect
information and where a I goes right so
you know if you think about your
business if you upfront with your skill
right tell people hey I'm gonna be
recording your answers to help you in
the future which no matter how much
people are scared about privacy they'll
do in certain certain things you're more
private about than others so if the way
the skill gets really crazy is the
collective AI and and brainpower of it
over time so you hunt you know hopefully
hundreds and thousands and tens of
thousands of people inputting
information it itself gets smarter and
starts giving better advice because it
sees pattern recognition of people
answering the same way based on what
they'll remember - [ __ ] you you know
right and so I think what your ambition
is is to build the most seamless skill
for me to talk to it in natural language
and guide me through whatever you're
trying to guide me through to fix or
prevent my injuries so let me give you
an example your head weighs on average
13 pounds so if you draw it back over
your shoulders where your ear is in
alignment with your shoulders yeah
you've taken off that pressure if you
just bring your head with them how do I
look at my phone that's right that's
right I I did the angle on you yeah
you're at 45 degrees that's 50 pounds of
pressure on your neck and shoulders on
those muscles and joints if you would
just bring that head back over your ear
and shoulder you would take that
pressure off and you wouldn't age those
joints as fast and that takes you
moments and if you change you will
change for so many people in the world
that's the kind of information I want to
give people so so on that note for me
first of all that's very exciting news
doc I'm so excited and I'm excited for
you I know myself super well so I think
I'm gonna hire somebody to follow me
around yeah four hours a day and you
just make sure that my head shoulder
ratio is perfect there's there's a
really easy trick because what happens
what you do is
yeah bring your phone down here if you
would just bring your arms into your
body and draw your children up you know
it's crazy sure Hannah doc I wish Jordan
was here right now he's really been
pushing me
he really to his credit I'm happy to
talk to him I'm happy to see you at
matcom I love it I appreciate it so
listen here's what I would say you've
got a really great thing and we didn't
touch on this and again I'm trying to
leave the details for the rest of the
speaker's briefings a skill is AI you
navigate you can talk back and forth a
briefing is a piece of information
everybody here can start their briefing
very quickly if you have 365 thoughts
you've got a briefing that can be there
every day what you just did was a more
of a tip hey did you know like you know
your ability to create a briefing which
would cost you nothing in comparison to
a skill where you need a developer a
briefing recording it uploading it you
having a tip of the day for prevention
that is absolutely something that you
can get started on right away and little
tidbits like that do you have 365
tidbits yes great then you should start
a briefing tomorrow okay awesome Thank
You doc Thank You max and everybody
needs to raise their head up oh gosh so
write 50 and I don't think my head's 13
I think my head's like 12 or so I'm 46
oh god
hey Gary first thanks for being our CMO
for free appreciate that it's my
pleasure nice to get back a little yeah
thanks um so my son when he was in
fourth grade
he had his self-confidence wrecked by a
teacher who nicknamed him Tweedledum
right
oh lucky wouldn't want that teacher my
wife okay I got close can you give me
the author's name what's that
being serious like what the [ __ ] that
teacher like I want to make a post to me
like this teachers a piece of [ __ ] well
here's the here's the good part fifth
grade teacher okay the fifth grade
teacher saved them turned him around I
mean but in the same year that his fifth
grade teacher became a good friend of
mine he lost his son that same year the
fifth grade teacher yeah so he was
digging deep in the same year I don't
know how he did it so now this is a few
years later
he he's obviously still hurt in a big
way now this guy he has it in him to be
an amazing unbelievable off-the-charts
podcaster okay he has so he has the love
that he's got and the ability to
communicate it I saw him do it my son I
seen him do with other kids I'm trying
to convince him but I know I push ya you
know cuz I'm afraid to where do you live
North Carolina do you think you can get
him up into my office for 30 minutes
yeah probably yeah let's do it
okay alright I'll convince them thank
you you know I think you know hopefully
that happens and please email me Gary
vaynermedia say I'm the guy with the
teacher and the podcast we'll set that
up if you could do it if he doesn't want
to do that or box at that or you can't
get it done you know
this is kind of how and I've got to wrap
up and thank you for being here everyone
one last time this is how I think about
it and I think you're seeing it through
my actions right now in my content and
it's no different than commencing the
way you get it done is by never giving
up telling him you should do it right
literally the second I before I got on
stage here you can go to my Instagram
right now actually that'll be fun I'm
not going to say what it is go to my
Instagram right now and see what my
latest post is it's exactly what I think
you need to do with this teacher because
it's the only move we've got cool cool
thank you everyone
[Music]